ich habe jetzt schon normales Bett
gebaut ich habe schon Bett gebaut dass
den Schläfer einfach raus wirft wenn
sein Wecker klingelt damit er garantiert
wach wird und jetzt bauen wir ein
heftiges Designer Bett ich habe mir
nämlich schon lange überlegt mal einen
dieser River table mit Epoxidharz zu
bauen aber dass das ja schon dutzend
immer ergibt habe ich mich dafür
entschieden was Neues zu bauen und zwar
ein River Bett das habe ich nämlich
zumindest auf Youtube noch gar nicht
gesehen ich habe das auch mal eben in
die Bild KI eingeschrieben und die hat
nach einigen nicht ganz so geil
Ergebnissen recht schnell dieses absolut
heftige Design ausgespuckt und das
versuchen wir jetzt in echt zu bauen
dieses Video wird unterstützt von Emma
mehr dazu später obwohl uns die KI die
Designarbeit echt gut abgenommen hat
müssen wir das Teil trotzdem erstmal in
CAD konstruieren damit wir hinterher
genaue Maße haben mit denen wir arbeiten
können jetzt wird das geschafft ist
brauchen wir Holz und River tables in
die später flüssiges Epoxidharz gegossen
wird sehen ja immer besonders geil aus
wenn man so wildes und verwachsenes Holz
hat im Baumarkt gutes Holz zu bekommen
ist eh schwierig aber sowas gibt's da
einfach überhaupt nicht also sind wir zu
einer Schreinerei gedüst die
restbestelle aus ihrem Holzlager
verkauft aus dem wir uns jetzt was aus
können der passt perfekt der ist richtig
geil der ist schön uneben ey das ist
perfekt es ist komplett perfekt das
sieht richtig geil aus nice ich war
jetzt gerade noch mal im Baumarkt hat
bisschen Holz besorgt und zwar einmal
hier unser Konstruktionsvollholz fürs
Bett untergestellt und einmal diese
Platte da raus machen wir unsere Boxen
Gießform neben all dem wilden Holz haben
wir noch drei ganz grobe und unebene
Eichenblätter gefunden eins davon ist
schon breit genug fürs Bett zwei davon
müssen wir aber zu einem großen zusammen
bleiben und da die jetzt unterschiedlich
hoch sind werden die noch an der CNC
Plan gefräst
[Musik]
diese Bretter sind für die Optik von
außen aber das tragende Gestell bauen
wir aus deutlich günstigeren
fichtenbalken die man hinterher aber gar
nicht mehr sehen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und bevor wir jetzt an die Rückenlehne
kommen können wir das mal das Fußteil
das nämlich auch ein richtig geiles was
sind das Echtholz waldkanten
rustikal der soll hier so hinkommen
nur nicht ganz so hoch dass wir jetzt
einmal abgeschnitten
[Musik]
bis auf das krasse Kopfteil mit
Epoxidharz ist das jetzt schon mal ein
fertiges Bett wie immer bei unseren
bedbauprojekten bin ich froh dass immer
uns auch diesmal eine ihrer Matratzen
zugeschickt hat und dieses Video mit
ihre Emma one Federkernmatratze
unterstützt
wir bequem diese Matratzen sind und wie
gut ist halt mittlerweile einem Jahr
darauf Schlaf brauche ich euch ja nicht
mehr zu erzählen was aber neues ist der
ostersale der noch bis zum 10.04 geht
bei dem ihr bis zu 40% Rabatt altert
plus zusätzlich 5 % Rabatt mit meinem
Code aber selbst wenn ihr das Video erst
nach Ostern seht kein Problem mein Code
ist nämlich ganze 6 Monate gültig und in
Deutschland Österreich und der Schweiz
einlösbar der Rabatt gilt auch für die
super bequem Kissen Betten und weiteren
Produkte die ihr bei immer rund um das
Thema Schlaf finden könnt was immer so
richtig krass macht ist dass ihr einfach
eine Matratze mit kostenlosen Versand zu
euch geliefert bekommt und innerhalb von
100 Nächten doch nicht zufrieden seid
lässt immer die Matratze kostenlos
abholen und gibt euch das Geld zurück
viel wahrscheinlicher ist aber dass ihr
die Matratze lieben werdet und von zehn
Jahren Garantie auf den Matratzenkern
profitiert und von den abnehmbaren
Bezügen die man einfach waschen kann
auch also klickt auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung und gönnt euch auch
erholsamen Schlaf so jetzt fehlt aber
hier noch einen Kopfteil und jetzt haben
wir hier mega geiles Holz und das habe
ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen so
hingelegt wie es später auch aussehen
soll und da das später mit erstmal
flüssigem Epoxidharz ausgegossen wird
brauchen wir dafür auch einen Rahmen und
dieser Rahmen den brauche ich jetzt
gerade
den Rahmen brauche ich eigentlich erst
später aber ich zeichne jetzt schon mal
genau den Ausschnitt an
dem Holz brauchen werden
[Musik]
dann geht das nächstes an die
Handkreissäge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt noch ein ganz großes Tier
[Musik]
man sieht ja auch richtig was hier für
Verspannungen im Holz sind hier ist es
noch wichtig dünn und dann wird es hier
immer dicker immer dicker immer dicker
aber weil das Holz sich ja auseinander
gedrückt hat wir haben jetzt hier eine
wunderschöne Rinde ja ich finde die
extrem hübsch allerdings muss die leider
weg die muss weg weil das Zeug einmal
nicht haftet weil das irgendwie morsch
wird und sofort also wir sind immer weg
jetzt kommt der Party
weg ist kommt das Teil hier dran ich
habe so eine Aufsatz noch nie benutzen
[Musik]
jetzt geht's zur Sache jetzt mixen wir
das Epoxy also das Kunst hat weil ich
das jetzt nicht unbedingt so in die
Augen kriegen wir erstmal meine
Schutzbrille oder davor erstmal den hier
und dann die hier und dann sogar die
hier das sind jetzt zwei verschiedene
Flüssigkeiten die zusammen rein
ich brauche davon jeden Tropfen das Zeug
war nämlich so teuer
und jetzt die letzte
hier ist übrigens die Farben irgendwie
so blau dass mir überhaupt nicht gefällt
ich hoffe einfach darauf dass es am Ende
geile aussieht sonst bin ich ziemlich
sauer weil das war echt wirklich teuer
das Zeug
oha sieht ja voll geil aus
[Musik]
und um das ganze jetzt um zu rühren
haben wir einfach diesen wilden Aufsatz
für den Akkuschrauber gekauft weil die
Flüssigkeiten tatsächlich jetzt 10
Minuten führen sollen
[Musik]
einmal Pack und einfach rüber kippen
sich erstmal diese Kanten hier schön
manuell damit sollte man dafür dass
zwischen Holz und die Boxen keine
Luftbläschen eingeschlossen werden
[Musik]
jetzt kommt dieser River table Effekt
richtig gut zur Geltung obwohl es
natürlich ein River Bad wird und es ist
auch immer mehr Flüssigkeit und immer
mehr Druck und ist tropft immer noch
nichts raus
[Musik]
und drei Tage später sind wir hier auch
ausgehärtet ja
[Musik]
genau wie bei den Brettern die das
Gestell des Bettes verdecken kommt auch
die Rückenlehne nochmal unter den Fräser
damit das Holz genau planen mit dem
Epoxidharz ist um Holz und Epoxy Plan zu
machen muss ca 1 cm vom höchsten Punkt
an abgetragen werden
[Musik]
das abfräsen macht trotz Absauganlage
nicht nur eine megasauerei sondern hat
auch den halben Tag gedauert aber
nachdem ich noch mal den Feinschliff
gemacht habe mit schleifpapieren von
80er bis 800er Körnung ist das Teil
komplett glatt
okay was folgt ist der geilste Vater im
ganzen Video kommen jetzt hier das Öl
drauf
so ruhig nicht geizen ich glaube das
Alter das sind voll die geilen fraktale
Alter
[Musik]
sieht mega heftig aus auch wenn ich
jetzt keine Ahnung habe wieso naja gut
jetzt kommt hier gerade
ich das ganze mal
[Musik]
wir kommen jetzt das Holz richtig schön
zur Geltung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
trag jetzt mal hier das Kopfteil ins
Bild das sieht schon sehr sehr krass aus
[Musik]
gut dann
[Applaus]
das ist schon sehr sehr hübsch
[Musik]
das ist das fertige Bett sieht mega nice
aus die schönste Stelle Verdecke ich
gerade natürlich ich finde ist wirklich
gelungen mit Epoxidharz gemacht haben
und ich fand es ursprünglich ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen aber jetzt wo ich
echt sehe finde ich extrem schön
tatsächlich und das Wetter war auch echt
super günstig das ganze Holz haben
insgesamt für ungefähr 150 Euro gekriegt
der Ultra Schnapper Epoxidharz auch
ungefähr 150 € und dann die Beine also
insgesamt 320 € fürs Bett gestellt super
krass dann fehlt ja quasi nur noch eine
gute Matratze die er über den Link in
der Videobeschreibung natürlich bei Emma
kriegt ich finde das Bett mega geil ich
hoffe euch hat das Video auch gefallen